Marvel's insanely popular black panther
was packed with amazing moments for
newcomers and comic fans alike but there
were a few details that only the biggest
Black Panther fans truly understood do
you know warning spoilers ahead memorial
Mountain as his father to chacas
appearance early in the film showed two
challahs Black Panther is just one of a
long lineage of super-powered Wakanda
protectors and while T'Challa is the
most well known Panther mashenka is one
of the greatest and oldest in that line
in the comics mashenka was one of the
first to done the garb and the name of
Black Panther and the originator of both
wakanda's isolationist leanings and the
religion of the Panther God in the Black
Panther movie but shingu is subtly
referenced with the name of the mountain
over which the mound of vibranium is
stor mount bazinga cutting-room costume
concept art from Marvel's Black Panther
at the art of the movie showed to
chalice smart-aleck sister Shuri decked
out in a vibranium black panther suit
herself with the same gauntlets she
ended up wearing in the actual climax of
the film from the concept art it seems
like the Black Panther creators were
interested in at least hinting at the
comic storyline in which Sheree takes
over as the black panther and queen of
Wakanda there may be a winking reference
to that storyline in the actual movie
itself as well on to chalice challenge
day Shuri is the one who raises her hand
for the right to challenge him for the
throne of Wakanda a moment that's played
for Laughs when it's revealed that she
was just tired of wearing an
uncomfortable outfit a new Nakia while
every character in the movie is changed
at least slightly from their comics
origins the character of Nakia is almost
a completely different character in the
comics the dora milosz a were two
challahs brides and waiting bodyguards
that were betrothed to the king
indefinitely unless he were to actively
choose them accordingly the comics
version of Nakia was adorable Ajay who
became obsessed with the child to the
point of becoming the mind-controlling
villainous malice in the movie
Nakia is brave selfless and two challahs
romantic equal rather than a spurned
lovelorn teenager so you would be
forgiven for thinking that the
filmmakers kept nothing but the name
still there's a nod toward her door
Malaysia comics Rou
when the kia don storm elijah armor for
the final battle soldier or wolf as
foreshadowed in the infinity war prequel
comics ii post credit sequence in black
panther showed Bucky and Wakanda
seemingly cured of his brainwashing with
kids nearby calling him the white wolf
in the comics hunter the white wolf is
wakanda's spymaster as well as two
challahs caucasian adopted brother
connecting one caucasian former spy in
Bucky to the white wolf could be just
fun reference or it could be
establishing where Bucky will be
spending his time following the
conclusion of Avengers infinity war
maybe there's a new superhero identity
for our favorite brainwashed super spy
once he hangs up the Winter Soldier duds
pan-african unity when T'Challa
Nakia and a coy a enter the casino in
South Korea to capture Klaw it's the
start of one of the best-looking action
sequences of the movie but one excellent
detail is kind of hidden
Nakia is dressed in all green a coy way
in all red and T'Challa is wearing his
characteristic black and together their
color scheme matches the pan-african
flag considering that one of the
defining themes of the movie is banding
together beyond tribal barriers it's a
beautiful way of depicting that theme
through three different characters who
band together to do what's right thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]